[Music]
thank you
welcome to the stage vice president of
cloud Ai and Industry Solutions at
Google Cloud Jun yang
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone
welcome to Google Cloud next 2023. it is
so great to be back in person this year
my name is Jun Yang today I'm excited to
share with you what's next with
generative AI at Google Cloud
AI is undergoing I'm undergoing a major
shift with the Riser Foundation model
now you can leverage these Foundation
models for variety use cases without ml
expertise with little to no training
data
this is really a game changer for AI and
is significantly accelerating time to
value for Enterprises to adopt AI
when it comes to generative AI
our goal is to bring the power of
Enterprise ready generative AI to help
organization innovate faster
as Thomas mentioned in the Keynote
Google is the only company that offers
the full technology stack from the high
performance AI infrastructure to
Foundation models to the tools that use
these models to build custom models and
application with vertex AI
to integrate these generative Ki
capability into gcp product with duet AI
across the entire stack we have
Incorporated security
privacy compliance and control all of
these requirements the Enterprise need
to adopt generative AI
if you want to learn more about duet AI
please attend a host of other Spotlight
sessions on the talk about how we're
bringing duet AI to Google Cloud
products to bigquery to workspace and
more
in today's session we're going to focus
on vertex AI
our comprehensive AI platform that help
Enterprises to build AI powered
application and services
duet AI itself is built on vertex AI as
well
so we have seen tremendous demand from
our customers on vertex AI since April
of this year the number of customers
engaging with Google Cloud on generative
AI has grown by 15x
our customers are partners
are leveraging generative AI for variety
of use cases
as you can see on this slide here we
have a number of customers some of them
you saw a little bit earlier in the
keynote and we're excited to have Bose
gitlab and World Bank joining us today
you'll hear from them just a little bit
at Google
with the rise of generative AI we can
democratize AI far beyond the data
scientist enabling a much larger range
of users like developers and business
users to take advantage of AI
we understand that based on customers
use cases and technical skills they will
consume generative AI differently
so we're powering our application like
contact center Ai and document AI with
generative AI capability to help
business users achieve more value
quickly with new functionality like
summarization accelerated bot building
and more
developers a much larger audience
Canal leverage our powerful Foundation
models to infuse generative AI
capabilities into their application for
transformative results
vertex AI combines the foundation model
capability with search and conversation
to allow developers to easily and
quickly build chat Bots voice bot
knowledge search and many many more use
cases
AI practitioners like data scientists
and ml Engineers can easily access
Foundation models and the tools needed
to tune deploy and monitor these models
in vertex AI platform
and of course everything is built on top
of a world-class infrastructure
and all of these features are generally
available and you can use them today
so we'll get started to talk about
Foundation model first
a foundation model is a large model
that's trained on the vast Corpus of
data it recognizes predicts generates
words images text videos and more
it is capable of doing many tasks out of
the box with little to no additional
training
we have launched multiple families of
Google Foundation models across
different modalities
from text to code to images to speech to
embedding and more
all of these models are now generally
available and immediately accessible via
vertex AI
today we're excited to announce new
versions across several of these
Foundation model families
starting with our text and chat model
palm2
many of you have asked
hey can you increase the input token
length we heard you
with this new version we have increased
the input token length by four times
from 8 000 tokens to 32 000 tokens
making it easy for you to process longer
form documents like research paper legal
briefs books documents and more
you've also asked for more language
support
and we're announcing General
availability for 38 language today
including Arabic Chinese Japanese German
Spanish and more
we also have 100 more language in
private preview
we're also launching upgrades to our
text to image model imagine
imagine provides capability such as
image generation editing captioning
visual q a and more
with this version this new version we
have significantly improved the quality
of the generated images
we're also introducing a very cool
feature style tuning which some of you
saw at our keynote this morning
leveraging this feature Enterprise can
now create images aligned to their
specific brand guideline or other
creative needs with as few as 10
reference images
and style tuning is actually available
today
continuing on the topic of AI generated
images
we are pleased to be the first cloud
provider to enable digital watermarking
for generating images
digital watermarking on vertex AI is
powered by Google deepmind sense ID a
state-of-the-art technology that embeds
Watermark directly into the image of the
pixels
and making it invisible to the human eye
so it does not damage the quality and
it's difficult to remove
we're launching digital watermarking in
experimental and are working with a
selected set of Partners and customers
to learn and refine this capability
we have also upgraded Kodi
our text to code model
with this new version customer will see
up to 25 quality improvement in the
supported programming language for code
operation code chat co-generation and
more
additionally we're also on announcing
the preview of streaming API for code
generation and chat which streams the
model output in real time thereby
improve their developers experience
text a SQL as the name suggests is
converting natural language to SQL allow
customers on the users who may not be
familiar with SQL to be able to leverage
this power with just plain language
in addition to the base Foundation
models we're also providing Foundation
models for industry-specific use cases
like SEC Palm for cyber security domain
and medpong for medical domain
we have been working with a small set of
customers like Bayer farmer HC HCA
Healthcare Medtech and more to
understand how medpom could be used
based on the feedback and overwhelming
customer demand we're excited to expand
the pre-private preview for medpom now
more customers can Leverage The Power of
matpom to unlock new use cases in
healthcare
in line with our
commitment around fostering an open
ecosystem
today we're announcing the addition of
metas Lama 2 and code Lama to our model
Garden
codelama was added to vertex AI within
48 Hours of its release
really talking about really kind of
speaking to the power of the platform
here
of course the you know all this the
launches are done with card Enterprise
Readiness and the security control built
in
we're also pre-announcing the addition
of anthropics Cloud 2 to model Garden
with these additions Google Cloud now
provides the widest variety of models to
choose than any other hyperscale
provider
we have our own models we welcome models
from partners and of course we Embrace
open source models
with access to over a hundred curating
models in vertex AI
customers has a flexibility to pick the
best model for their particular use
cases
zooming in on llama2
I'm excited to announce that Google
cloud is the only cloud provider that
provides both adapter tuning and
reinforcement learning with human
feedback for llama 2. this allows the
organization to tune lamatu with their
own Enterprise data while continue to
maintain full control and ownership of
their data
now
I'd like to introduce David de Santo
Chief product officer from gitlab to
talk about how they are leveraging
Google's Foundation model Cody and palm
welcome David
[Applause]
thank you for joining us today
thanks June
for those here who are not familiar with
gitlab we are fundamentally changing how
development security and operations
teams work together collaborate and
build secure software
from planning to coding to building to
securing to monitoring and deploying
we help organizations build more secure
software faster
we're able to do this because we provide
the most comprehensive Enterprise Dev
Tech Ops platform delivered as a single
application
and now this application is way more
efficient with the use of AI
I've been meeting with gitlab customers
all over the world and they share the
same concern
their concern is will my software my
source code my intellectual property be
used
without my consent
and I'm sure some of you have the same
concern as well
that concern is what led gitlab to
Define our vision for how we will use AI
our vision is built on top of three key
tenants the first is apply AI across the
entire software development lifecycle
this is because even if you made your
developers a hundred times more
effective something around them will
break
our second is to lead with a privacy
first approach
meaning that your code stays your code
and we will not use it for training or
fine-tuning of models
we also leave the same way on prior I'm
sorry we leave the same way on
transparency as well
our goal is to tell you what AI models
we're using For What and how those
models were trained
and finally we want to lead with a
best-in-class AI experience meaning that
we're choosing the right AI model for
The Right Use case this is to help us
avoid the whole if my llm is a hammer
everything must be a nail
so to achieve this Vision we needed the
right partner and Google cloud is that
right partner
this is because Google Cloud shares the
same strong sense of commitment to
Enterprise Readiness and privacy
and we're thrilled to be working with
Google Cloud on delivering our vision
for AI powered workflows as part of the
software development lifecycle
today we're leveraging poem 2 Foundation
models including the Kodi model family
to deliver AI powered experiences to
users
all involved in creating software that
can be product managers marketing teams
whoever they are they get the Boost from
AI
this partnership has come fully to life
and we're able to deliver value to our
customers every day
Google Cloud's vertex a model Garden has
helped create one of the best outcomes
so far and with that I want to introduce
you to get lab Duo
gilabduo is our suite of AI powered
features that enable users across the
entire software development life cycle
with the goal of making everyone 10x
more efficient
with gitlab Duo you have an AI powered
partner to help you ship more secure
software
deploy more effectively
ensure your CI CD pipelines are healthy
and make sure you catch vulnerabilities
before they're in production
it's so exciting to see gilab Duo come
to life and help everyone contribute
more effectively
to be to bring this to life we selected
the right foundation models for each use
case to ensure we're delivering a
best-in-class AI experience
for our users this means that their
teams can now get up to speed much
faster during planning write better more
secure software more efficiently
get through code review faster and I can
tell you that's a big pain point for a
lot of customers as well as resolve
vulnerabilities faster in fact resolve
them before the code is committed and
pushed into production
and just like Ai and gitlab all this AI
functionality is part of the same
unified workflow allowing development
teams security teams and operations
teams to work more effectively powered
by AI
now one of the features I wanted to
highlight for you today is gitlab Duo's
code suggestions
it actually was mentioned in the keynote
earlier today as well Co suggestions is
built on top of a palm 2 family
specifically the coding models to give
developers efficiency from suggesting
and completing code
suggestions keeps developers in their
Flow by completing lines of code
creating and defining Logic for
functions generating test cases and so
much more
code suggestion supports 14 languages
today and is supported on the major Ides
that customers of GitHub use and I'm
sure a lot of your teams use as well
including go Labs web IDE
vs code visual studio
jetbrains and neovim and we have more to
come
and of course code suggestions is built
on top of the same privacy as a critical
function
this means that your source code will
not be used to train the feature
and we're excited to be bringing the
newest ad models mentioned this week at
next two code suggestions including
today making available the ability to go
from comment to code within our IDE
a we'll have lots more announcements
related to the integration of all the
other models that are coming out
in close I want to share the code
suggestions is actually available right
now for free to any gitlab user
if you're not GitHub user you can go to
gitlab.com and sign up but it's free on
gitlab.com getlab dedicated that's our
self our single tenant SAS offering as
well as gitlab self-managed customers
while we have the future in beta so I
highly encourage you to check it out get
the power of Google AI as part of your
gitlab experience
and get the Boost of efficiency our
customers are telling us about being
able to get through coding code review
and applications to planner production
much faster and with that thank you all
and back to you June
thank you David
so great to see these capabilities in
action
we have just talked about a number of
advancements on the foundation model but
we didn't stop there
we ask ourselves while the foundation
model are powerful capable can we do
better
the answer is yes
we have developed a set of model
augmentation tools to augment the
capability of foundation model further
to make them more useful for Enterprises
let me highlight a few of them today
Enterprises want Foundation model
outputs to be factful
grounding stability to force the model
to provide output that's based on user
specific user-specified Source material
to ensure that responses from Foundation
models are factual and verifiable
extension is a set of tools that help
developers to connect the foundation
model to real-time information and
real-world actions via apis
and finally
tuning is ability to be able to
customize a foundation model with your
Enterprise data to provide more accurate
and relevant results
so let's walk through each one of these
in more detail
first grounding
today I'm excited to announce the new
grounding capability in vertex AI in
preview
this will enable our customer to ground
their responses on their own Enterprise
data
and the best part is that customer can
now enable this integration out of box
without any development work
so let me show you example
on this example it shows a generic
answer you would get from a foundation
model on the question about 401k
contribution
now if we ground the data on your
Enterprise data the response now is
augmented with the company specific
information about 401K matching
information that's sourced from your
Enterprise data now that's much more
useful for the for your user
extensions
extension Powers empowers the developer
to easily integrate real-time data and
real-world actions into generative AI
powered application
we're excited to announce vertex AI
extension in preview
vertex AI extension is designed to be
Enterprise grade with Enterprise
encryption data control and security out
of the box
developers can leverage Google build
extensions for services like bigquery
alloy DB out of the box as well as
partner build extensions from data
stacks mongodb redis and more
of course developer can also build
upload test and manage their own
extensions
for folks who are familiar with the
react framework we're also including the
agent support to provide Enterprise
grade orchestration capability with
Advanced logic to make extensions more
capable you see that in just a little
bit in the vertex AI search and
conversation area
so just about every Enterprise has a
large repository of data I often get
asked how do I tune my data what's the
best method well my response is well it
depends
the best method to use for customizing
the foundation model depends on the
specific task it depends on the type of
training material you have available and
also depends on your in-house ml skill
set
let me highlight a few options that we
offer and some considerations on one you
might choose one option over the other
going from left to right
the tuning message the tuning mechanism
gets more sophisticated requiring more
data and generally costs more to tune
so starting with the simplest one prompt
design that's the simplest one this is
where the user is designing the prompt
and optionally adding a few examples
this does not require ml expertise and
can be done directly through the UI or
API
the second method is adapter tuning
which requires a bigger training data
set with tens to hundreds of examples
and some more computer training
this requires some ml expertise
what it yields is a adapter model which
is additive to our base model
and together they're able to generate
more customer results for your
Enterprise
because we clear create a clear
separation between the adapter layer and
the base model adapter model give you
the power of customization while
protecting your data and IP
today we're excited to announce that
adapter tuning for text and image is
generally available and adapter tuning
for chat and code is in preview
for more advanced users we also offer
reinforcement learning with human
feedback
so this allows a user to be able to take
the human feedback on the model output
to tune the model using vertex AI
Pipelines this technique takes a higher
level ml skill set
based on strong customer feedback we're
excited to announce that reinforcement
learning with human feedback is now in
preview
finally
full fine tuning which is where the base
model weights are adjusted to fit the
model for specific use cases
this is a good choice for customers who
have a large amount of training data and
advanced ml practitioners in-house
now you can leverage vertex AI to
customize selected open source large
language models like T5 Bert with full
fine toning capability
choice is really at the heart of vertex
AI customer can pick the right model the
right tuning method the best suit for
their business needs and business skill
sets
now with all these choices all these
models and model augmentation options
customers now have a different dilemma
which is how do I know which model is
best for my use cases how do I know
which augmentation method is best used
for this particular model
so we believe it's imperative to have a
systematic way to evaluate the quality
of different models and different
augmentation tools
at Google Cloud this is something we do
day in day out to look at our models and
deciding whether this is the model we
want to put out there for uh for for
consumption so I'm happy to share that
we're making our model evaluation tools
and framework available to our customers
two general approaches on the model
evaluation both are supported in vertex
AI evaluation
the first approach is automatic metrics
this is where the customers can define a
task specific metric for their use case
customer can then evaluate the model
output against the desired output and
vertex AI will help determine the
quality of the given model candidate
the second approach is automatic side by
side
in this scenario customer can use a
large Foundation model sometimes
referred to as a teacher model as a
proxy for human evaluator this approach
helps to narrow down and select the most
promising candidate from the model
family quickly for human evaluation
which in turn help to reduce the both
the cost and the time for evaluation
Switching gears a little bit
for most data scientists the AI work
really starts in a notebook
collab is a notebook that's developed by
Google research to bring Google doc like
collaboration features to data
scientists
since this release in 2017 colab has
been adopted widely
today colab has over 7 million users and
two-thirds of the Fortune 100 companies
are already using collab
so I'm excited to announce the preview
of collab Enterprises on vertex AI
collab Enterprise is now the common
notebook interface across multiple
Google cloud services vertex Ai bigquery
and more
with collab Enterprise users can now get
up and running quickly with zero
configuration experience
we have also added generative AI powered
code completion and generation
capability to help data scientists to be
more productive
and of course the popular collaboration
capability of collab carries over
enabling sharing amongst team members to
accelerate experimentation
now I'd like to invite my colleague
Nikita namojashi to the stage to demo
some of the latest features and that we
have just talked about over to you
Nikita
[Applause]
thank you June today I want to show you
how to use vertex AI to explore and
customize Foundation models across
different data modalities
we'll be using genii Studio which
provides the simple UI for you to
interact with these models
if you want to extract real insights
from text Data you often need that data
to be in some structured format like
Json so that you can store it in a
database and analyze and process it at
scale
so I have saved a prompt to help us do
that
I'm going to open up this prompt here
and let's say that I want to analyze a
bunch of tech specs for a bunch of
different project products instead of
doing this manually which would take me
a bunch of time I can use a large
language model to efficiently extract
structured data from text and we can
prototype this really quickly in gen AI
Studio
so let's zoom in on this prompt
the first thing we do is instruct the
model to extract the tech specs and then
we specify that we want this done in
Json format
after that we have a string of text and
this is just a bunch of information
about the Google pixel 7.
there are a few different models I can
choose from including the Palm 32k model
that June mentioned which allows for
longer document inputs but this is a
pretty short prompt so we'll just stick
with the standard model for now
and we'll click submit
and what we get back from the model is
the key pieces of information have been
extracted as product attributes like
Network Ram processor and then their
corresponding values for the pixel phone
entirely in Json
and with the expanded language support
that June mentioned we can now prompt
the model in a variety of other
languages
so now I'm going to open up the same
prompt but this time it's in Spanish
so we'll go in and we'll select our
model
and then we can scroll down and click
submit
and what you'll see is that the model
restructures the data as Json again but
this time all of the keys and values are
in Spanish
so now we've seen a few examples of
going from text to text but we can
actually go from text to other data
types like code or image so next let's
check out Cody which is a text to code
model
I've saved one more prompt for us to
test out so I'm going to open up this
prompt right now
writing Docker files is a pretty common
task for developers and it's something
that I can get Cody to help me with
which as a data scientist it makes my
life a whole lot simpler
so I'll zoom in on this prompt again and
we're now instructing the model to write
a Docker file for us but this time I
have some requirements I need the
specific version of python and then I
want some additional data science
libraries installed like Pi torch and
tensorflow and numpy
to use Kodi all you need to do is make
sure that you've selected one of the
code models
and then we can scroll down and click
submit
and what we'll get back from the model
is a full development environment ready
to go
and this environment contains all of the
packages that I need to do data science
so next I'm going to use Kodi to help me
with actually writing some ml model code
so this time I'll type in a new prompt
generate python code for a pi torch
model to do
classification oops
I always get a typo
all right
using the mnist data set so if you're
unfamiliar mnist is a standard data set
for benchmarking and tutorials and
machine learning so what we'll get back
is a bunch of Pi torch code that we can
use to get us started on our data
science Journey
so to close off there's one last data
type that I want to check out with you
which is image so let's navigate to The
Vision section of gen AI Studio where we
can input text prompts and generate
brand new images
if we scroll down under style you can
select from a variety of predefined
styles like sketch photography or even
cyberpunk and as June mentioned you can
also tune your own custom Styles as well
so because we know that no machine
learning demo is truly complete if no
one mentions kittens or puppies I'm
going to type in a cute kitten as our
prompt and let's just bump up the number
of results and we're going to generate
these images in the watercolor Style
and what we'll get back from the model
is a variety of images oops I actually
opened up one a variety of images of
kittens and this distinctive watercolor
style that we could use for different
visual assets
so I hope that this shows you how to use
vertex AI to explore and customize
Foundation models across different data
modalities and I'm really excited to see
what you build and with that I will hand
it back to June
thank you Nikita
for that great demo to Showcase how easy
and how quickly the model responds to
the request
so we've talked about the Myriad of
investment in advancement we've made to
the foundation models we then talked
about the various augmentation tools to
extend the capability of foundation
models to make them more useful but we
didn't stop there
having spoken with hundreds of
Enterprise customers two of the most
frequently requested use case for
generative AI is around search and chat
application like being able to do a q a
with your own internal knowledge base
like having a chatbot to be able to help
both your internal employees or external
customers with their request
this is why we introduced vertex AI
search and conversation
bring in our years of experience in
Search and conversation to complement
Foundation models enabling Enterprises
to develop these type of experiences
with ease
vertex AI search and conversation
previously known as gen nav Builder is
now generally available
now if we break down these search and
chat use cases we see a common pattern
what we have is that we have an input
from the user that can be coming in as a
form of a text voice or pictures
then we have orchestration layer that
needs to understand what is the intent
of the user and figure out how best to
answer that and the answer would come
from different places depending on what
the question so for example for a
question like what's your store hours
the answer would come from a simple
website search
for a question like hey what's the
difference between Roth IRA and Ira the
answer could come from the knowledge of
the foundation model
for a question like what's my vacation
balance
now the answer will come from your HR
System via the extension
the orchestration layer allows
Enterprises to design the generative AI
powered experience and also guide user
down the desired path for quickest
resolution
finally the output needs to be presented
back to user that can be in the variety
of format whether it's text voice or
multimodal response
so let's take a closer look at vertex AI
search
you may have seen Google's search
generative experience
with vertex AI search now you can offer
the same experiences to your employees
Partners or customers with built-in low
code multimodal and multi-term
capability
vertex vertex AI search applies the
state-of-art information retrieval and
deep retrieval techniques leveraging
embedding and so on to in to Enterprise
data out of the box and can be easily
leveraged by customer even with very
limited technical expertise
we search one of the things our customer
care most about is really data accuracy
and reliability
so I'm excited to announce that vertex
AI search results is also grounded on
your Enterprise data with auditable
citations
now I'd like to introduce Robin
Ai and ml platform lead from World Bank
to talk about how World Bank is using
and leveraging our vertex AI search to
reimagine search and generative AI from
the Google Cloud side welcome Ramen
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
I'm so happy to talk about how the World
Bank has partnered with the Google Cloud
as part of the early adopted program
particularly for vertex AI search as you
may all know World Bank is an
international organization focused on
development and primarily the twin goals
of eliminating or ending extreme poverty
and promoting Shad Prosperity these are
noble goals right but to achieve them
they require significant research
analysis and of course the operational
expertise given the scale of our work
and where we work on and the importance
of elevating the value of every dollar
invested Knowledge Management is
absolutely essential when it comes to
knowledgepole and print at the World
Bank our main objective is no different
from all of you it's getting the right
information to the right people at the
right time
the approach we took is also possibly
very similar
initially we started with investing in
taxonomies and tagging our content and
quickly starting started hitting the
limitations on them
then keyword search was next and just
like you we've also hit the limitations
with that method
and now the promise of generative AI
powered search
we are excited of about taking advantage
of DPI capabilities from these
foundational models to reimagine our
Enterprise search and we are working
with Google Cloud to see how we can
increase the value to our staff with by
minimizing the effort they take to find
this information
today we spend a significant amount of
time within the bank in content analysis
synthesis and generation
moving the needle on these steps with
generative AI will give us we hope
Explorer exponential benefits we consume
lots of information and the analysis is
usually focused on a very particular
topic the AI generated summaries with
the power of continued conversation with
natural language would be awesome
because that'll get us jump started we
consume and we produce so we produce a
lot of content and if our staff are able
to use Enterprise search to generate
summaries and use that to uh as part of
a zero draft that would be amazing
of course we spoke about the power of
conversation at the beginning and the
ability to have a conversation where
once you have some information you are
able to drill down deeper that would be
Priceless because the World Bank has 70
years of data which if we tap into it
elevates the amount invested in
development exponentially and finally
the ability to jump start these
capabilities with limited to no system
integration work sounds super positive
because you've all been in my shoes
where
mainstreaming of innovation is
absolutely critical right Innovation is
good but we have to mainstream it
our journey with generative AI search
has just started with summarization as
you can see vertex AI is able to provide
an AI generated summary based on a very
complex query
it's a question in natural language and
it was able to respond back as an
operational Analyst at the World Bank in
my previous life and I would have had to
look through multiple documents across
multiple years across multiple projects
and then looked at each of these
documents to generate this information
to summarize this Lessons Learned which
you can see on the screen not anymore
with vertex AI search not just
summarizing a response it also provides
citations
for all the generated response clearly
demonstrating the grounding on our known
data that June talked about for the
World Bank and as with any of UI
organizations this is huge from a trust
and verification perspective
I also get the top results for my query
so that I can dig deeper and then use
that information based on whatever I
need right pretty much like we do now
finally the multi-turn search
functionality allows me to ask follow-up
questions reduces the time taken for
each of these deep types and takes the
time it takes us from a few weeks to a
few hours
we are excited to continue our journey
with Google Cloud to unlock other
potential gen AI capabilities around
generation and conversation we'll keep
you posted on our progress for now back
to you June and thank you for the
partnership
thank you Robin for joining us today
it's great to see the tremendous
progress that we have made together
so moving on to generative AI powered
conversation
with vertex AI conversation we allow
developers to bring all these
capabilities together to easily build
human-like safe and useful chat Bots and
voice Bots
not only can these bod understand the
user's intent and then provide them
users with a personalized answer
and then be able to generate multimodal
responses across text audio images they
can also be enabled to support
transactional capability such as making
a payment or completing an order
so how is that possible
let's take a look
with vertex AI conversation developers
can start by easily connecting the bot
to relevant data sources whether it's
your documents your website or other
third-party systems
leveraging vertex AI data connector
with just a few clicks developers can
now get a bot that can converse and
answer questions from their Enterprise
data
to supercharge the bot with
transactional capabilities developers
could leverage the extension either by
build something they build themselves or
using existing ones built either by
Google over one of our partners
developers can also execute common tasks
by just adding pre-built tasks like
check order status explain Bill and more
finally
if a developer wants more control over
how the bot executes specific important
tasks they can Leverage The Playbook
feature which you saw at the keynote
this morning
to be able to specify what they need in
natural language step by step with
instructions on how to execute the task
to the bot in the same way you would do
to human agent this greatly simplifies
how you build a bot and really we're
talking about 10x reduction in terms of
time to build a bot that's really useful
together
Foundation models search and
conversation offers a quick path to
value for many many Enterprise use cases
we have seen early adapter building a
variety application from travel planning
to Food Service to banking assistant to
website chat Bots realizing measurable
gains in business metrics like customer
satisfaction employee productivity cost
savings and more
now I'd like to invite my colleague
Kalyan papathi to the stage the demo how
easy it is for developers to build
amazing generative AI experiences on
vertex AI over to you Italia
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you June hi everyone so I'm here
to show you how you can build and
configure a search and conversation app
just like the one Raman showed in a few
easy steps the example I'm going to be
using is searching through knowledge and
internal knowledge basis I'm sure we've
all asked questions like these at some
point let's get started
so I'm going to start my journey in the
Google Cloud console as you can all see
here
I'm going to select my app type as
search
I'm going to keep the advanced features
on because we want to show generative AI
I'll give my search engine a name my
test
search engine
and I'm going to pick a location for
where the data should be indexed for now
I'll just pick Global and I'll hit
continue so that's the first step now
the second step is to create a new data
source and we want to make this as easy
as possible we have out-of-the-box
connectors to public websites Google
bigquery Google cloud storage and even
rest apis
but we know that data within your
organization is not all in one system so
today we're launching out of the box
connectors to third-party systems we're
starting with jira Salesforce and
Confluence and over the next few months
we'll have many other connectors
for the demo let me just stick with
Google Cloud Storage
so I'm going to select a Google Cloud
Storage bucket here I have one setup
called Enterprise docs next I'm going to
click select I'm going to leave the
selection as unstructured documents
because I'm showing document search
and then I'll hit continue I'll give the
data store a name
my test
data store
then I'll hit create
so that's the second step now the third
easy step is to connect your search
engine to this newly created data store
I'm going to select it and hit create
and that's it we've got our search
engine connected to our data store now
it can take a few minutes to index the
data so let me switch to an application
that I created this morning I'm going to
go back to apps I'm going to click the
application called Next underscore
search
now we're ready to start testing our
search engine but before I do that I
want to show you the data that I've
indexed which is from the same Google
Cloud Storage bucket that I showed you
before
so in here I've got about 50 documents
someone health benefits someone
understanding your pay stubs Etc just
like you would have within your
Enterprise knowledge basis
I'm going to switch to configurations
now we've got a few different options in
terms of the user experience
I'm going to pick search with an answer
here
I'm going to leave snippets on and then
let's start searching
and for this let's focus on the right
hand side of the screen
for my first search query
I'm looking for vacation policies at
symbol which is the fictional company
that I'm working with so I'm going to
say what is the vacation
policy at symbol
okay
so you'll see we get a response but
there's three things here to highlight
one just like Google search does you get
a set of results of your most relevant
search results
then you also get a nicely summarized
answer to the question that you've asked
right so you get you get some
information on your vacation policy and
third and probably the most important is
what you see here in Brackets
now we know that large language models
have a tendency to hallucinate
which is sometimes they can create
information and the information may be
from outside your data sources so we
have invested heavily in grounding these
llms which means that we're trying to
make sure that the information generated
by these large language models is coming
from your data sources and we can trace
that information back to these data
sources through citations which is what
you see here in Brackets now this
grounding in citations is really
important for us to be confident about
the output generated by the llms
now let me switch to a different type of
experience a conversational one I'm
going to click search with follow-ups
and I'll ask a different question
what are the benefits
at symbol
right so just like before you'll see a
set of top results so this is Google
search technology at work on your data
we get a nicely summarized answer just
like before and this answer you'll
notice is a little more conversational
because you can use this in a
conversational chatbot experience
but here you can also ask a follow-up
and this is the power of conversational
search and keep in context so here I'm
going to say tell me about healthcare
because I'm interested in healthcare
benefits
you'll notice I haven't used the term
benefits in my second search right so
this is the llm keeping context and
continuing the conversation and just
like before you see results you see a
nicely summarized answer and this is
about health care benefits even though
we've not used the term benefits
and I can keep going
and in case you're wondering what
happened to citations don't worry we
still have them in the apis
and that brings me to my final point
everything I showed here is also
available via the API and the system is
highly customizable for your needs you
don't like the UI you can switch it out
you want to bring your own embeddings or
llms you can do that too
with that I'll hand it back to June
thank you Kalia
for that great demo I think the thing I
want you to regards to remember is just
how easy how quickly you can actually
get a search engine up and running with
a variety of use cases and you can also
add conversational chat to that as well
so when it comes to generative AI
nowadays we get a lot of questions about
Enterprise Readiness about data
governance and privacy security and
compliance reliability sustainability
safety and responsibility
these pillars are really the Cornerstone
of our approach to Enterprise readiness
now I'd like to highlight a few of the
Investments we've made in this area
starting with data privacy
the most important thing to remember
about data privacy is that your data is
your data let me first Define your data
your data includes the input prompt the
model output the metadata the training
data your human evaluation feedback and
so forth we believe all of these are
part of your data and your IP we do not
use your data to train our own model so
you can rest assure that you can use our
product confidently knowing that your
data and your IP are protected
moving on to security and compliance
all of our generative AI offering are
built on top of Google Cloud
infrastructure with the same high
standard on security protocols
for vertex AI platform we have recently
launched VPC security control
customer managed encryption key data
residency and access transparency
the same control is being rolled out to
vertex AI search and conversation in the
coming months
when it comes to responsible AI
we have a comprehensive set of
responsible AI tooling including safety
attributes model evaluation bias
evaluation content moderation recitation
check and more all of these tools to
really help customers to understand and
test their models and thereby reduce the
risk of negative or harmful outcome for
their use cases
on this slide it's a good example of
responsible AI showcasing our capability
around safety filter
we classify over 15 harmful categories
and provides a confidence score so you
can set safety filters with threshold
that's appropriate for your particular
use case
you can also set up automatic blocks if
the threshold is breached
We are continuing to invest in this
space and will help our customers using
generative AI responsibly and
effectively to transform their business
and finally we're working closely with
our partners across the entire stack to
help our customers harness the power of
AI
for example
we partner with Foundation model
creators and open source model providers
and making their models available to our
customers through vertex AI model Garden
we partner with leading tool providers
for generative AI development
we also partner with top SAS providers
to help them integrate AI into their
Solutions
and finally we partner with leading
consulting firms and system integrators
to help Enterprise adopt generative AI
together was our SI Partners we're
working to train more than 150 000
experts on Google Cloud AI to really
meet the demand of our customers
we are still at the very early stage of
generative AI Journey
we're excited to see The Accelerated
pace of innovation in this area and the
potential for AI we look forward to
working with all of you to unlock the
power of generative AI
all through the next three days we have
a series of amazing sessions planned for
you to help you learn and experience
this exciting space of generative AI
thank you so very much for joining us
today and enjoy the rest of next
foreign